الاجواء تتوتر في معسكر البرتغال ريال
مدريد يغيروا سيارته بعد عقدين من الزمن
وان فانتينو يطلب هدنه في اوكرانيا هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم هنا العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان تبيعات مقابله كريستيانو رونالدو
قد وصلت الى معسكر المنتخب البرتغالي بعد
المصافحه البارده التي قدمها
برونوفرنانديز لاعب يونايتد لزمالك مباشره
[موسيقى]
نجمه يونايتد السابق بانه سائمه من الدفاع
عن رونالدو في كل مره يفسد فيها البرتغالي
الامور وعرف عن ريو في الفتره السابقه
دفعه الدائم عن زميله السابق رونالدو لكن
في قناه سبورت كاس الخاصه به اعتراف فارس
دي ناند بانه لا يستطيع جلوسنا والدفاع عن
ما قاله رونالدو في المقابله التي ستبثه
في وقت لاحظ
[موسيقى]
اعلن نادي ريال مدريد الاسباني عن توقيعه
عقد شراكه جديد في قطاع السيارات التي
ستكون كهربائيه لاعبون نادي الملكي
استمتعوا في السنوات السابقه بسيارات اودي
ذات المحركات القويه والتي تعمل بالبنزين
لكن هو بيحاسب العقد الجديد المباراه مع
شركه بي ام دبليو
سيارات كهربائيه بالكامل حسب بيت تقارير
اعلاميه بين اعتمد على العقد الجديد تبلغ
سبعه ثمانيه مليون سنويه
في خبرنا الاخير طلبت جنى انفنتينو عقده
هدنه في اوكرانيا لمده شهر واحد اي خلال
الفتره التي ستقام فيها منافسات كاس
العالم وقالت لهم في قمه جي 22 بان منظمه
فيفا تعنى بالرياضه فقط لكن هدفها هو
توحيد العالم ايضا من خلال لعبه كره القدم
مضيفا بان هذه الهدنه قد تكون الخطوه
الاولى الاحوال الطريق الى السلام بين
البلدين
[موسيقى]